ciao a tutti oggi è successa una cosa
terribile
mi sono pesato per un momento ho pensato
che la bilancia mi stesse ricordando il
pin del mio bancomat poi ho capito che
quel numero cinque cifre erano solamente
i chili del mio culo ma oggi non voglio
essere negativo perché ho trovato una
soluzione voglio condividerlo col mondo
dal momento che non posso mangiare
quanto vorrei mi sto perdendo un sacco
di programmi di cucina cioè diciamo che
mangia con gli occhi minuto di
radiazioni granoche il tubo catodico con
le ciglia ne sto vedendo un sacco
proprio un botto dovrebbero darmi sulla
fiducia dodici stelle michelin norme
sono diventato tipo cannavacciuolo sono
povero io amo che aveva solo
specialmente quando da quelle poche
bonarie alle persone che illustrano le
spalle
avete presente masterchef adecco potete
riconoscere i concorrenti che hanno
ricevuto così una una gentile carezza
dalla cannavacciuolo molto facilmente
sono quelli che non hanno più le braccia
scherzi a parte masterchef per me è un
mistero sono arrivati alla settima
stagione domani c'è la finale è ancora
nessuno è stato arrestato perché
masterchef quel programma in cui i
concorrenti invece che a cucinare vanno
in tv a farsi maltrattare noto non sai
finta tonta sei solo tonta cioè la
cucina c'entra non troppo non ho capito
perché quando i giudici si incazzano
devono mortificare i concorrenti
pubblicamente e ho visto persone in
lacrime davanti frullatori gli chef che
che prendono i piatti li lanciano
addosso alle persone ma ancora non li
avessero servito una sacher e con una
ganache a la merda
roba che dopo che vedi come li trattano
il sergente di full metal jacket ti
sembra karol wojtyla se io fossi stato
un vincitore di masterchef avrei speso
in montepremi in analisi quelli che
invece non ce l'hanno fatta ad arrivare
sul podio li potete trovare ancora nel
tevere morti suicidi i loro corpi
galleggiano in fila nella prima stagione
all'ultima gonfi di acqua salmastra e
poi ci sono le sfide ma non le sfide
tipo vince chi fa il tiramisù più buono
no no questi cui vengono temprati col
fuoco del monte fato per l'avvento dei
cavalieri dell'apocalisse per il presso
il test di oggi dovrete prendere i
vostri compagni ucciderli a mani nude e
di sassari e servirci di qui su questo
altare sacrificale e le persone non è
che chiamano i carabinieri
no loro così vanno si fanno si può
insultare si fanno rizzare i capelli
tipo soldato jane quella sera secondo me
quelli tornare a casa e così si può
stare da soli con sedano il piatto che
ho portato per questa sfida si chiama
tramonta tibetano di coulisse con bruno
a di seitan es atleti fuori da quattro
coulisse bruno a saab lei per colpa di
queste persone adesso tutti quanti sono
share pazzeschi persone che fino
all'altro ieri sembravano le caccole e
adesso si sentono ratatouille a il dopo
cuoca una volta sono andato a cena da
questo nemico ci ha eletto il menu
sembrava una versione di greco né io
posso tirare fuori i vocabolari ogni due
secondi perché la tua insalata sempre
una supercazzola che poi ti portano da
mangiare dimostrano il loro capolavoro e
ti sale una tristezza infinita un lutto
piatti di ceramica enormi con questo
capezzolo di cibo al centro piano di
aceto balsamico perché se non usi la
classe di aceto balsamico non sei
nessuno mi raccomando di averci il
parkinson quando la metti perché devi
colpire tutto tranne che il cibo poi per
carità è magico è l'unico raviolo
presente sul piatto e ti sembra di aver
assaggiato l'ambrosia degli dèi chiudi
gli occhi e per quel minuto le guerre
spariscono e noi lo devo dire per me il
cibo non è un'esperienza sensoriale no
vernet un rapporto sessuale violento io
e cibo amicis fondo se tu per caso
via servire così a mia nonna una
coulisse di lampone con la ghiaccia di
cioccolato quella lì ti prenda sprangate
le gengive pure li prende il piatto
etici fa un clistere nel coulisse con
quello che cercatori propinarle
calcolate che un dolce che preparano
nonna si chiama biancomangiare sapete
cos'è e bianco e si mangia fine altro
che quei nomi assurdi tipo tarte tatin
il nido di crusca orgasmo al mango io
una volta ho sentito cocktal al vapore
di crudo di parma che non capivo se devo
mangiare o farci l'aerosol a me mancano
cucina di una volta quella che non aveva
nomi strani o o presentazioni assurde ma
solamente sapore quella che quando
mangia vi e poi che cavi two sca ricavi
e e salutavi due scarti organici come si
salutano gli innamorati in stazione
quella che non aveva bisogno di tanti
ingredienti ma solo di tanto appetito
per oggi è tutto
passo e chiudo che mi è venuta fame
poi per carità evitiamo fraintendimenti
perché tu prendi quell'unico davvero
presente sul piatto e ammazza il cane
facciamo silenzio cane